j'imagine que vous avez déjà entendu
parler d'abraham brandt
les gens l'appellent le prédicateur il
habite maintenant à marc termote les
corps ont été retrouvés au même endroit
de la rivière il faudra découvrir
l'origine de ces meurtres il faut faire
vite
qu'est ce qui vous amène par ici nous
cherchons à faire une halte pour reposer
nos chevaux vous devez rencontrer le
pasteur
avons des visiteurs et un venu un match
ferme
combien de temps pensez vous rester le
temps de nous reposer quelques jours
vous êtes un homme qui est à la
recherche de quelque chose bien il se
trouve par un étrange coup du sort que
c'est cet homme qui a tué mon père il y
à 22
david tu vas tuer cet homme
vous n'êtes pas en sécurité j'ai déjà
essayé de m'en aller
on dit de lui qu'il a reçu la grâce de
dieu priant hors stade
vous n'avez pas l'air de vous sentir
bien si ça va non non vous avez de la
fièvre
ce qu'est ce qui vous n'avez aucune idée
de ce qui se passe ici
je suis un texas ranger envoyé par le
gouverneur lui-même
pas comme si j'avais pour chasser cet
homme toute ma vie
qu'est ce que vous faites un enfant
ils finiront en enfer
un seul mot je te fais sauter la
cervelle de mettre dans la rivière comme
il l'a fait
[Musique]
amener leur je savais que tu essaies
redler
ça vous l'aviez pas prévu j'imagine